Donald Trump's press secretary Kaley
Magnani as some are calling her mckenna
knee McEnaney I don't know how you
pronounce her last name but by that I
mean you personally but you know who I'm
talking about she could barely keep her
lies straight yesterday at a 26 minute
press briefing that she gave and we have
to come to the realization that they are
barely going to even try to hide their
wrongdoing at this point in time so when
she started doing these press briefings
I would live stream them and I would
sometimes say let's do an over under and
put it at three minutes will it take
Kaleigh more than three minutes to tell
her first lie or less than three minutes
and she told a lie after like 20 seconds
so the next time I streamed one of her
press briefings I said let's do the
over-under at 20 seconds and then she
told the first lie within 12 seconds so
there's not even a point to doing that
anymore these are brazenly lie riddled
press briefings let's get into what
happened yesterday
when we learned yesterday that Donald
Trump tweeted threats to the governor of
Michigan about if you vote by mail I may
not send you a domani that you need
including for the recent flooding in
Michigan we knew that Caylee was going
to be asked questions about this and she
was and one of the questions was a good
one which is you know you've already
admitted that Trump talks to the
Michigan Governor regularly why tweet a
threat about vote-by-mail rather than
just communicate it directly
Kaleigh mcenany said that that's called
transparency yes jack Kaley how often
does the president talk to director vote
or acting director vote from the
to to the Acting Director of OMB often
he just was in the Oval Office with the
president so they do speak often I don't
have a readout of the president's
schedule but they do speak regularly if
he wanted to flag to him his concerns
about Michigan why don't you just tell
him instead of sending a tweet because
the President believes an unprecedented
transparency and I'm sure you as a
journalist Tom are very eager and
excited when you learn about the
president's decision-making process in
real time whether that's on Twitter for
me here up at the podiums you just said
that way that was your reasoning for him
expressing but I'm saying this is a
transparent president and I think that
that's something that you should be
allotting rather than questioning as to
why he decided to tweet this this is
truly a mix of 1984 and brave new world
and a totalitarian dictatorship where
facts simply don't matter war is peace
defeat is victory accusing a governor of
a crime on Twitter without evidence is
what they call unprecedented
transparency and good for the reporters
in the room I mean this is pretty
lukewarm praise but they kept asking
about this issue and Kaleigh kept doing
this move where she refers them to the
campaign your that's really a campaign
issue you're gonna have to talk to the
2020 Trump campaign about that why is
she doing that because the question is
about something Trump said as president
about the disbursement of funds that he
manages as president why would that go
to the Trump campaign and also Caylee
Mackin Annie herself is a lawyer nope
that's for the campaign which is
basically a way of saying go ask
somebody else can you tell us what law
specifically the president thinks the
secretary
in Michigan groped by sending out the
applications and did the Secretary of
State in Georgia also break that law by
sending out applications for their
buyers I mean I reference you to the
campaign these are ballot questions I
reference you to the campaign on this
the president and their employer my
sermon employers the White House so
that's not a campaign question that's
the president saying that you have an
absentee ballot so I would refer you to
the campaign on that front and I would
note to you that many of those ballots
that are submitted via mail can be
fraudulent I cited to the bipartisan
study I can read it again maybe you
weren't paying attention when I read it
the first time so read it again
President Carter a Democrat not a
Republican and James Baker concluded
that these ballots forming the largest
source of potential voter fraud so if
you cast a ballot via mail and you do so
fraudulently that would be an illegal
act and I'd point you to that and for
further I'd point you to my former
employer which is the Trump campaign
also important I want to remind you and
I'm gonna become a bit of a broken
record on this vote by mail fraud is
mathematically non-existent yesterday I
gave you the numbers 250 million people
have voted by mail in the last 20 years
there are seven to eight cases not 7 to
8 percent there are seven to eight cases
of vote by mail fraud per year there is
way more in person voter fraud of course
there are more in person ballots cast
but those numbers also are completely
insignificant this type of what I call
retail strategy voter fraud is
essentially non-existent do not fall for
it now here's a really Orwellian moment
where Kaylie mcenany was asked about
Susan Rice Susan Rice is Barack Obama's
former national security adviser she
recently a letter that she wrote a memo
that she wrote in 2017 which is
exculpatory of Barack Obama in the
context of Obama Gate was recently
released I told you about it yesterday
Kaleigh mac and annie does this thing
where she has a page in this notebook
with disinformation that she will turn
to whenever a question is asked that
even tangentially relates to something
she has in her book now that's fine
that's not I'm not criticizing her for
having notes
it's called being prepared it's called
search that's okay but the thing is if
Kayleigh here's one word that relates to
her pages she will turn to the page and
read the page even if it has nothing to
do with the question and in this case
the name Susan Rice was mentioned in a
very specific exculpatory context and
Kaleigh turns to her Susan Rice page and
she reads two minutes of unrelated
attacks on Susan Rice sort of sounds
like she's arguing that Susan Rice's
letter was just a lie and I'm actually
going to play the full two minutes for
you normally I would I would just slice
out the key part but what you really
need to see Susan Rice's name is
mentioned Kaylee turns to a page about
Susan Rice spends two minutes reading
unrelated things about Susan Rice and
then quickly ends the press conference
and leaves this is happening at almost
every single one of these press
conferences let's take a look
I apologize for subjecting you to two
minutes of this but it's important and I
know you brought up Susan Rice in that
context but I'm going to bring her up in
another context that's equally as a new
newsworthy and that is the email that
was Declassified from Susan Rice on
Inauguration Day which is so peculiar
set the scene it's an odd Eurasian day
you're moving out of the White House
this is the most powerful building on
planet earth Susan Rice is moving out
reflecting on her time here and what is
she doing she's not packing her boxes
she's not being nostalgic about her time
in the White House what she's doing is
writing an email worth three times she
writes that President Obama emphasized
to conduct the investigation into
Michael Flynn by the book by the book by
the book she writes that three times as
a Shakespeare said thou doth protest too
much Susan Rice he didn't have the Susan
Rice part in there but I'll add that in
to she was asked specifically about the
unmasking and Michael Flynn a fruit
after she discussed it on January 5th in
the Oval Office with Obama after she
wrote this email to herself on
inauguration day she was asked by a good
journalist judy Woodruff about this
email and she said about the unmasking
and Michael Flynn not the email but the
a masking she was asked specifically
about núñez his claims specifically so
me clarify was known as his claim and
she said I know nothing about this so it
was a
and then Susan Rice since no one brought
it up to me I will bring it up to you
her attorney said that this was the
first opportunity three weeks after this
oval office meeting that she had to
write this email memorializing her Oval
Office meeting with a Barack Obama
discussing Michael Flynn it was her
first opportunity she said interesting
because she had an opportunity in those
three weeks On January 10th to do a
passing of the baton event with none
other than Michael Flynn where she
praised him wished him success and
talked about the great transition into
the White House and then on January 12th
she was able to participate in a story
that published on that date in the
lifestyle section of the Washington Post
so she never had time to write this
email until inauguration day as she's
rushing out the door when in fact she
had an opportunity to do all of those
things I'll leave that with you thank
you for bringing up Susan Rice not in
the context that I wish but for allowing
me to share that so the reason I played
all of that is that it's really
important for you to understand that
this is what they claim is radical
transparency and it's not of course it's
reading pre-planned talking points and
then walking off the stage before
anybody can say hey that stuff you just
said has nothing to do with my question
and the saddest part the most tragic
part of this is that Trump is loved ER
they think she's doing so well at her
job she doesn't answer questions she
does 20-minute press briefings
yesterday's was 26 minutes after showing
up 30 40 minutes late that it's her
speech and her questions 26 minutes
she reads non sequitur material from her
notes and then she leaves and the
trumpets are gleeful because to them
this counts a strength turning weird at
that like yesterday she turned a
question back on a reporter don't you
agree XYZ but that's not what a reporter
is there for lying barely keeping it
together attacking the media walking out
abruptly that's the state of affairs and
the trumpets are thrilled because they
believe she's owning the liberal media
we live in a very very backwards country
right now let me remind you monday is
Memorial Day we will be doing a one-day
huge membership special if you've been
thinking of
about getting a membership membership of
course the number one way to support our
show Monday is a perfect day to do it
Trump's phone call wasn't perfect Monday
is the perfect day to get yourself a
membership if you want to be notified
about the Monday special just get on my
mailing list at david pakman.com one of
our sponsors today is a company i love i
reached out to them about sponsoring the
show and i'm thrilled that they are it's
a company called chipmunk baking they
make delicious fresh cookies and
brownies they use healthy ingredients
like sunflower seed flour al ulos monk
fruit sweetener so everything is
sugar-free low-carb they use healthy
fats it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
if you are on one and even though
there's no sugar you really would never
be able to tell the difference they have
the same taste the same texture as all
the desserts you love but you can enjoy
them without any of the guilt
everything that chipmunk baking offers
is delicious I'm personally a huge fan
of what they're doing you should
definitely give it a try for yourself
and they're giving you ten percent off
your entire order when you go to david
pakman.com slash cookies and use the
coupon code Pakman I've put a link right
underneath the video